bonjour je n'y a jamais un jour bonjour
à toute la martinique secrétaire général
du parti progressiste martiniquais
lequel ppm a désigné hier c'est candidat
alors on va y revenir les candidats du
ppm au sein de l'alliance pour les
prochaines législatives
avant de parler de ceux qui ont été donc
désigné parlons d'une grande absente
catherine conconne on ne l'a pas entendu
et on n'a pas entendu parler d'elle
durant ces préparatifs de candidature
qu'est ce qui explique cela une mise à
l'écart elle même s'était dite prête
éventuellement être candidate dans
n'importe quelle circonscription n'ont
pas du tout la procédure d'investiture
ça fait plus de trois ans maintenant que
l'ensemble des balisiers je rappelle
qu'il s'agit pas de d'une personne en
particulier
c'est l'ensemble des militants des
balises et qui début septembre dans ça
fait plus de trois mois ont été
consultées d'abord sur la stratégie avec
un calendrier prévisionnel qui a été
respectée sur le dépôt des candidatures
est ensuite la commission d'investiture
s'est mise en place
et puis après les sujets parts à partir
de ce que les militants propose et puis
le comité national à partir décide à
partir des dépôts de candidatures qui
ont été faits qui ont été faites
elle n'a pas déposé de candidature donc
effectivement il s'est agi de discuter
des personnes qui ont déposé leur
candidature militants du parti
progressiste martiniquais mais vous avez
les quatre qui sont sortis hier sont
ressortis parmi plusieurs candidats
alors on n'a pas toute la liste
vous dites que les balisiers enfin tout
ce qu'il ya de très nombreuses
candidatures effectivement dont celle de
catherine conconne par exemple il y a eu
des propositions par des balisiers
maintenant après le candidat en fait la
personne préposée est interrogée pour
savoir si elle accepte ou pas elle n'a
pas accepté en l'occurrence donc
effectivement le comité national
recentrer son débat et le comité
d'investiture si les personnes qui ont
accepté d'être candidat et de porter les
couleurs du parti progressiste
martiniquais donc finalement il n'a pas
accepté d'être candidat
d'après ce que vous dites je n'y a
jamais à fait bien ça parlons de
catherine conconne alors venons à fort
de france là aussi on a cru que c'était
tout à fait naturellement que serge
letchimy allait être désignée par le ppm
il est le président du parti
progressiste martiniquais
il s'était déjà déclaré candidat à la
candidature est dans le communiqué
d'hier soeur on voit que c'est par
réquisition et acclamations qu'il a été
désigné
candidat dans la circonscription de
leurs deux fils il n'a pas déposé sa
candidature à son débat l'isiq en
déposer sa candidature jusqu'au dernier
moment
je rappelle que nous a enfin conclu en
juin et le congrès prothèse sur
justement la mémoire la formation et la
transmission est notre président
aujourd'hui dans et dans cette culture
de la transmission néanmoins à travers
la proposition de rodolphe division
président d'honneur du comité national
et président d'honneur du parti
progressiste martiniquais
il a été décidé par l'ensemble des
membres du comité national à l'unanimité
un de réquisitionner et 2,2 public de
plébiscité par acclamation serge
letchimy de façon à lui montré très
clairement qu'en ce moment il ne peut
pas se permettre de passer la main et
d'aller au combat mais y'a pas à pas une
contradiction parce qu'il avait annoncé
très tôt qu'il était candidat à la
candidature
enfin sa propre succession si vous avez
plus d'informations je suis en bas je
suis sylvania que celui-ci l'avait moi
je vais vous vous retrouvez à me
retrouver d ajouter je m'étais déjà vu
avec la région sage de ces messieurs
sujet des candidats et d'ailleurs il a
répété à plusieurs reprises qu'il
n'était pas candidat qu'il serait
l'homme de la transmission par ce que je
vous dis on a engagé le comité national
aujourd'hui a été renouvelé après 80 %
il ya beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
femmes et beaucoup d'hommes
ce travail sur la forme assure la
mémoire la transmission a commencé
effectivement nous sommes vraiment dans
cette dynamique lors des réquisitions
acclamations plébiscite ça fait pas un
peu culte de la personnalité c'est un
petit peu on pas du tout et jimmy il
aura besoin de ça va devenir faut pas
oublier qu'il est aussi le centre de
toutes les critiques depuis un certain
temps par un certain groupe est
aujourd'hui nous avons leader nous avons
quelqu'un qui est visionnaire et sans en
faire un culte nous pouvons quand même
également considéré et reconnaître la
valeur des militants que nous avons au
sein du parti progressiste martiniquais
il fait parti d'un feu de lens qu'à
porter haut les couleurs du parti
progressiste martiniquais il
il travaille considérablement sur
l'intérêt supérieur de la martinique
et effectivement c'est à l'unanimité et
collectivement je le dis hein ce n'est
pas une personne ou une autre et c'est
le président d'honneur ou de le désirer
qui a fait cette proposition le comité
national a suivi
il faut que l'on montre que nous sommes
tous derrière nos leaders et en
l'occurrence ces rejets chimiques qui je
le rappelle est président lui-même du
parti
alors dans le sud c'est david din al que
le ppm à désigner un élu des anses
d'arlet c'est bien ça qui qui qui est
encartée au ppm il est bien sûr la
médina les militants du parti
progressiste martiniquais d'ailleurs
dans la réorganisation du parti que nous
mettons en place dans la circonscription
du sud
il a il apparaît aussi le fait un
travail important au niveau de la
communication du bureau de la
circonscription du sud qui est présidée
par un militant du sud du parti
progressiste martiniquais très bien et
puis dans les circonscriptions alors
distinctement un du centre il y à serge
dallies et puis du nord daniel chomet
deux candidats qui voient déjà deux
candidatures annoncées ce matin dans le
france antilles de deux parties qui font
partie qui constitue donc ensemble pour
une martinique nouvelle je veux parler
de bâtir le pays martinique et puis le
mouvement l'eau rhinois de justin
pamphile
ces deux personnes sont annoncées comme
candidate aussi dans ces
circonscriptions donc faudra faudra
faire un choix entre d'une part serge
tally et josette manin est peut-être
qu'il y en aura d'autres
et puis dans le nord daniel chaumet ou
justin pamphile coûté le processus était
connu d'avancé au sein de l'alliance ce
qui avait été décidé c'est que chaque
partie avant la date limite pour pouvoir
désigner ses candidats à la candidature
au niveau de l'alliance maintenant
chaque parti qui intègre le mouvement de
l'alliance a fait ses propositions
le parti progressiste serbe a dégénéré
certainement y en aura peut-être
d'autres en tout cas à partir de
maintenant il ya une forme de conseil
des sages au sein de l'alliance qui va
pouvoir commencer à démarrer les
discussions dans une logique de voir
s'il est possible d'avoir une
candidature unique de l'alliance porter
fortement parle dans chacune des
circonscriptions vous nature unique
alors justement la suite en vue de ces
candidatures finale sur quels critères
ça va se passer et au moment de choisir
est ce que ce sera une voix pour chaque
partie parce que c'est vrai qu'on le
sait au nombre de militants d'élus c'est
le ppm quand même qu'ils qui domine cet
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
oui mais nous devons faire preuve
d'humilité comme nous l'avons fait
depuis 6 années effectivement même si le
poids on va dire des a dû en quantitatif
du nombre de militants et du travail
effectué et le parti progressiste
martiniquais appartient pourtant il n'en
demeure pas moins que depuis toujours au
sein de l'alliance
c'est une voix pas en mouvement et par
parti donc nous respectons les autres
membres de l'alliance nous sommes aussi
un membre de l'alliance et donc nous
allons faire valoir nos idées nos
valeurs et nous avons échangé discuté
parce que nous sommes en fraternité nous
sommes en solidarité de façon à faire la
martinique avance et donc je vous êtes
man et justin pamphile pour le moment et
les autres qui peut être salon seront
ont quelque chance quand même de pouvoir
figurent ils sont pas écrasés par le
poids du ppm au sein de paix régnera
aucun agrément je rappelle il faut
vraiment prendre de l'humilité il faut
regarder l'intérêt supérieur de la
martinique
il faut regarder quel est le meilleur ou
la meilleure candidate qui doit
aujourd'hui porté les couleurs de
l'alliance essayer d'offrir une
alternative une vraie espérance
aujourd'hui dans un pays à l'arrêt
depuis toute l'année 2016 vous regarder
je viens de recevoir le budget de la
sécu 2010 est très inquiétant avec plus
de 100 à 150 millions d'euros de moins
par rapport à 2016 en terme
d'investissement c'est extrêmement
inquiétant il faut redonner confiance au
peuple il faut une foi espérance et donc
nous en choisir les meilleures personnes
et l'alliance en termes et tracera un
lieu est vrai c'est déchirant quelques
mots en guise de conclusion c'est quand
même une échéance électorale qui est
importante pour vous le parti
progressiste martiniquais parce qu'il
s'agit aussi quelque part de se refaire
une santé après l'élection de décembre
2015 ce qui n'a pas été à un échec total
m'enfin bon
serge et de chimie n'a pas été réélu à
la tête de la cmfs fondamentalement ne
sommes pas sur la question des postes
c'est vrai que certains considèrent que
ce sont les élections qui sont les plus
importantes nous nous considérons que
c'est pas le côté électoral qui est
important ce qui en compte l'importance
et la portée des idées des valeurs un
projet est dans le calendrier il y à
cette phase électorale dont nous serons
présents de façon à défendre nos idées
nos valeurs essayer d'offrir cette
perspective on n'est vraiment pas sous
la question des postes
nous reparlerons évidemment de ces
prochaines élections législatives avec
vous johnny jarre et puis évidemment
d'autres acteurs politiques martiniquais
merci secrétaire général de l'upm
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
merci et ainsi à votre tous ces mets à
sa flamme à sénèque des bonnes journées